it's episode 163 of congratulations oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah dude what the [ __ ] sounds better
than that sometimes I'm not even drink
beer but sometimes when I do it so I
don't drink soda but when I'm drinking
the Lacroix for one of these [ __ ]
nitro caveman coffees cracked I crack it
open you know and drink it but dude I
crack it open
[ __ ] nothing's better than cracking
open nut cracking and open a cut
nothing's better than cracking open an
ice-cold one whether it be beer or soda
or nitro or cold brew or [ __ ] what do
you call it
Lacroix cracking it open you ever
[ __ ] crack open one and in summer
don't say that just so you know and hmm
here we go babies it's episode 1
something 160 something 163 and um I
held on having the podcast Wednesday la2
you guys speed what the [ __ ] dude why do
you guys being annoying as [ __ ] when you
know your boy drops podcasts Monday if
not Monday Tuesday and if not Wednesday
after Wednesday you've got problem but
very on the very rare occasion I'll drop
a podcast on a Wednesday but that
doesn't stop people from being annoying
his [ __ ] on the internet saying hey
where's the pot now I get rip-roaring
mad now I get I get blood red man ok but
here we are Monday I won't I want some
dude DN me hey man maybe I missed
something but this is the first podcast
you didn't do this is the first week you
didn't do nope doing it got it right
here dude and I'm and I held it because
I wanted to release it on Wednesday
because Wednesday
was the day I could do my big
announcement and if you didn't remember
that's what I said last week if you
didn't remember yeah but that's what I
[ __ ] said dude and the big
announcement this week Wednesday my
babies my special drops on Netflix
April 14th no pain that's the title no
pain Netflix April 14th your boys got
another special here it comes get it in
your cue what you can do is you can go
in you know what the [ __ ] if you're a
true baby if you're a real [ __ ] down
[ __ ] and sucking baby you know go to
Netflix right now you go to Netflix you
pull it up on your app you go to search
you type in no pain that's the first
thing that comes up Chris Thalia no pain
click on that and then you go remind me
right there we go just clicked on it
turn into a check mark go do that now
and watch it on April 14th now I'm gonna
do mm-hmm
what is April 14th is that a I don't
know what day that is but I'm gonna I
want you guys all to watch it that day
it's gonna come out you know and we're
all gonna you know I can't we I'm gonna
go crazy on Twitter babies I'm gonna
[ __ ] tweet you back that day and it's
a Tuesday so I'll drop the [ __ ]
podcast on that day maybe man I'll drop
the podcast the day before I'll remind
you that the shit's coming but no pain
April 14th Netflix and I will say hmm
I I've seen it I did it I was there when
I shot it obviously it was me it's the
best special I've done it's the best
taping I've had I did white male black
comic in on in for Comedy Central to me
that always has a special place in my
heart that was my first one all the
decks the deck was stacked I had the I
was this young gun coming up I was ready
to do a special I had this [ __ ] idea
where I know what's funny I got this
this is what's funny to me and I [ __ ]
I fell
really good about it that was a great
special I think for me I'm not saying
whether or not was grape I'm saying for
me was a great special not trying to
toot my own horn but for me I hate for
me it was it was great
I felt great about it it came out great
I loved it I hired my dad to direct it
kept it in the fam it was awesome I was
so Italian about it I kept it in the
family dude I should have called the
[ __ ] special spaghetti and meatballs
but instead I decided to go with white
male black commie
it was so Italian I kept it in the
family my mom came out my mom came out
sat in the audience I kept it in the
family it's like my last name was
[ __ ] Danzo Leo or some [ __ ] but it's
the Lea it's still Italian but anyway
should have called it spaghetti and
meatballs but I didn't and then I did a
second special incorrigible that was my
first Netflix special now I like this
special but to me
it was all the stuff that I still
thought was funny that I didn't put on
white male black comic so to me white
male black comic was like the bang and
[ __ ] and then incorrigible was the stuff
that was like the odds and ends it was
like the b-side of what my black comic
and I also think that the best stuff in
incorrigible was at the end and that was
by design because as a comic you put
your good [ __ ] at the end at the closer
the landscape has changed since then
because that special was about an hour
and 20 minutes now that's too long for a
special I didn't think about that back
then because that was like the 20th
Netflix special that they ever made and
I realized that people were watching the
shorter [ __ ] cuz they don't want to
[ __ ] invest their time watching the
best stuff that incorrigible is at the
end and I know that a lot of people
checked out of it because the beginning
of it
people always reference the beginning of
it and that's not the good [ __ ] and I
get all bummed because I'm like a half
[ __ ] you didn't watch people are
watching 30 minutes of the special I
know that so man on fight so
incorrigible is is fine
I liked it man I'm fired to me oh and by
the way incorrigible the taping went
great okay man I'm fired to me was top
loaded I put the banging [ __ ] up front
because I knew now that there was this
way that Netflix and the streaming
services were doing in it that you were
watching the first part
check it out so I put the bangin [ __ ] up
front the first 25 minutes dang get it
dang it dang it dang it dang it okay and
then ice and then I end it with a nice
sweet story that you know to me was very
for me and meant a lot in my life at
that time man on fire was my best
material for sure to me hands down now
there were technical difficulties
shooting the special the mic cut out I
had to redo some stuff
the audience was it sounds good in the
in the in the special but the audience
was okay so I was really trying to bring
it but not too hard for the audience cuz
you never want to bring it too hard for
the level of the audience you want to
some you want to kind of meet the
audience halfway the energy comes in and
it's not popping and it's not
unimportant and you got to make it on in
public but you can't go in with this on
and pop and energy right off the bat if
the enter if the if the audience is not
there so you got to take it you got to
meet the audience you got to go like
this hello audience shake hands with who
the audience is come on into my study
let's read a little bit about what's
going on and then let's go into the
kitchen oh the food's good though isn't
it yeah well why don't you come into the
[ __ ] and sucking room oh you didn't
know we had that but now it's on and
poppin you got to start with the for ya
and then you got to take him in to the
study you got to show him your book
collection huh very nice okay cool this
is the audience oh okay very cool oh I
like this wife read that before you take
him into the kitchen you give them a
little bit of hors d'oeuvres they're
like wow this is very tasty well okay
very cool that's cool you show me your
study and mother for you it was
impressive
it was it wasn't precedent now all of a
sudden here's the [ __ ] and sucking
room that's what you're always trying to
get to in a special is the [ __ ] and
sucking room but the audience is not
always there for [ __ ] and sucking you
got to convince them oh you're here for
the [ __ ] and sucking aren't you
sometimes there's 50 year-old Mormons in
your audience oh I don't know about that
well let me convince you about the
[ __ ] and second row okay so what
happens is the whole time I'm an on fire
I was trying to convince this audience
to come with me to the [ __ ] and
sucking room and a lot of people were on
board but some of them were just there
for a jolly good time whatever that's
fine dude they wanted to hang out in the
foyer and mingle and have an hors
d'oeuvre and that's fine too because you
can have a good time nor d'oeuvres
but that's like that conversational [ __ ]
that's like that [ __ ] was like oh wow
last night was really fun but was it fun
or did you really just kick it and learn
some stuff did you really just have
great conversation we reacting like an
adult now you know me that's not my vibe
I don't sit there not like an adult not
all night long I'm known for [ __ ] and
sucking so I'm gonna be in the [ __ ]
in second room you guys hang out with
the hors d'oeuvres that's what it was
like for me on fire but it was my best
material and you can't tell when you're
watching the special so that's that so
white male black comic up until no pain
white Bob let me say I'm leaving no pain
out of this wait am i black comic best
special all the [ __ ] cards fell where
they may all the the deck was stacked I
should say the Stars fell and aligned
okay incorrigible great taping but the
odds and ends of blackwell black male
white comic the stuff I left out so then
I was like okay men on fire that's best
material however audience they were in
order of audience some of them were
there for [ __ ] and sucking but your
boy wasn't gonna drag him so we had a
nice conversation no pain I decided I'm
gonna go for broke best material to me
best material I've done now this is the
whole deal you get you [ __ ] you grow
for me best material the audience bro
the audience it was like they just came
in in shorts they were down for sucking
and [ __ ] right away the audience the
first audience I shot great walked off
the stage
my agent goes like this what we don't
even need to we don't even need to do
the second taping the second taping
first five minutes in I was like oh man
this is the taping we don't even need
that first audience so the first
audience came from [ __ ] and sucking
the second audience came I mean you know
whatever is on top of higher than
[ __ ] in second but my point is the
material the audience and guess what
dude
I fired my [ __ ] dad from shooting it
I fired him he's my dad and I fired him
I fired him I took him I hired him on
the SEC on the first episode
sewed thanking him for my whole
childhood can congratulations you're
welcome I've given you a job sure I only
gave you $7,000 to do it but this makes
up for everything you've done the second
one as if that wasn't enough hire them
again
for $7,000 now that's $14,000 I've given
my dad now I haven't given it to him but
Netflix did now whatever you're welcome
the third special hey Dad
here's another $7,000 you're welcome
times three and then yeah boy wanted to
make a change so what he did was I I
looked at my dad I said hey Dad you're
fired and then he said what and I said
hey Matt you want to do my next special
and my dad said this the best firing
ever and my brother came through and
[ __ ] took a Gatling gun and just it
was great dude the best dude and it
looks the [ __ ] it looks so good this is
the best special I've ever done and if
you don't think so what am I gonna do
dude what am I gonna [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] is no pain what am I gonna do it's
basically what I did in the
follow-the-leader tour I didn't want to
call that follow the leader because your
boy doesn't usually call specials the
tour names but it's called no pain mmm
man this [ __ ] is cool the background is
purple what the background it's purple
first one was blue second first one was
first one was first one and it was an
industrial vibe blue second one was
Rockstar blue third one was red and then
your boy goes purple Oh what is he
Prince anyway do it I can't wait for
this [ __ ] thing to come out and just
for it just that's it every special I do
I'm like all right maybe I'll maybe
that's it now what am I gonna do and I
don't think I'll be able to do it again
some of the [ __ ] I do is funny some of
it's not you know whatever guild it
[ __ ] deal with it that [ __ ] that
sunglasses mean we're the [ __ ]
sunglasses come down on your eyes and it
goes deal with it that's me bro
[ __ ] look at this meme the one with
Morpheus what if I told you deal with it
trying to put a [ __ ] square peg into
a round hole anyway do it I can't wait
for this thing to come out put it in
your cube go right now do it on your
phone put it on your list you watch ah
[ __ ] the day it drops like a true baby
anyway dude I'm being honestly annoying
as [ __ ] right now but this is it this is
what I did and I'm sorry but I'm not
dude haha
everybody's two people that's why I love
this that's why I left Tupac man
everybody's two people that's why I love
Tupac because he would make a song
called Brenda's got a baby and then he
would make a song called wonder why they
call you [ __ ] and people will be like
what the [ __ ] how could you do that
that's hypocritical and he would be like
everybody's two people and I would be
like we bei mean you know what I mean
everyone is kind of two people right
because sometimes you want to do [ __ ]
in second but also sometimes you want to
raise children kid do both of those at
the same time I mean you came with one
person in the race children anyway
anyway dude we're having a good time
dude having a really good time we're
having a really good time cuz I told you
we are I can't wait for it to come out
that's a whole commercial dude watch my
special called no pain mess on Netflix
and it just sometimes all the stars
align and you get a good taping that's
what it is but sometimes they don't most
of the time they don't I mean I did the
comedian's of the world that audience
was [ __ ] man it was like they were
just eating breakfast yeah bro I want to
do a special with no audience one of
these days and just just talk man that's
kind of what this is honestly this
podcast but anyway look it up add it to
your queue we've got other [ __ ] going on
though in this world how about the
coronavirus everybody dyin dude we're
over 120,000 people contracted the
corona virus the [ __ ] virus dick
corona and how many people died lots and
it's [ __ ] and I wasn't worried about
it and now guess what dude your boys a
little worried about it but it's all
good
you know the thing is it doesn't affect
kids that much thank God thank God huh
only elderly so we have to [ __ ] you
know it's not like I can't give it if I
do get I can't give it to my dad or
Brian Carolyn so but I do feel like a
lot of people are gonna get it and I
feel like it's gonna be bad you know I'm
the I'm very young so I think that it'll
be okay I'm not even 40 yet I think I'll
be okay if I ever get it but even though
it doesn't affect new boards I don't
want to give it to my kid I don't want
to give it to you know I don't want to
give it to these people I don't want to
give it I need to get one of those masks
I have a mask but they say you can't
touch your [ __ ] face yeah as [ __ ]
Ivan get rid of his literally just rub
in his face but you can't touch your
face because you get that coronavirus on
your on your hand and then you rub your
eyeball and then the coronavirus goes in
your eyeball and then all of a sudden
it's in your system you can't get it out
you can't suck it out like a snake bite
[Music]
so I just think the coronavirus is did
they really get it from that that food
market is that what it's from people
saying it's man man-made and [ __ ] I
don't believe in the whole [ __ ]
population control [ __ ] man oh yeah they
made it to control the population I
can't believe someone's actually that
evil just for no reason I mean not for
no reason I understand but like the
populations get out of control but like
somebody was saying they created it in
North Carolina and then they and then
they flew to China to [ __ ] I don't
know you know who knows I just can't get
on board with all these conspiracies
like we don't know what's going on
anyway so stop trying to figure it out
like there's no [ __ ] way there's no
[ __ ] way we know people are out there
like no this is what really happened but
what happened was oh yeah they created
it - how do you know dude that could
that could be the information that
they're hiding from you or it could be
the information that they're giving to
you look the information that they're
giving you could be a front it could
also be the real [ __ ] it could also be
the thing that they think that they're
you're gonna think is the front so
you're gonna get the other [ __ ] you're
gonna start to get the other [ __ ]
that could be [ __ ] four steps ahead
of you my point is this is what Trump
said about it there we go
this was my favorite you talk about the
coronavirus Trump on the coronavirus I
like this stuff what world is he talking
about science Trump loves science hi
Trump since when dude at [ __ ] [ __ ]
Brent dude David
[ __ ] Brent Peele surprised about
another stuff no they're not dude what
scientist has ever gone like this
Wow Trump I'm surprised how much you
know about science I have a natural
ability dude you can't have a natural
ability about [ __ ] science you know
what you can have a natural ability
about baseball dude it's science you
just have to learn it this hilarious
oh dude and for you [ __ ] cups that
are gonna be like boom in front of room
you liberal [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
up there's a clip that went viral me
talking about Biden making fun of them
can't stand the [ __ ] man I make fun of
something and then another guy or will
it's because you're liberal
no dude you don't get it it's crazy on
both sides I really get it I really get
it I like this stuff you like what
everyone dying
what are you sweaty look at these
[ __ ] guys in the background just like
standing all of them holding their hands
every one of these actions that have you
know so much about this maybe I have a
natural ability maybe I have a natural
ability I'm talking about science is
unbelievable dude maybe have a natural
ability when it comes to science dude
imagine here's what I want you to do I
want here's what I want you to do babies
for real if you're listening to this
right now I want you to pause the
[ __ ] [ __ ] after I said I would you
pause it I want you to take a ten second
break listen to podcast and I want you
to out loud maybe I have a natural
ability how do you know some everyone is
saying how do you know so I want you to
say maybe I want you to say out loud
everyone is saying how do I know so much
about this everyone is saying how do you
know so much about this I want you to
picture yourself in that situation and
say everyone is saying how do I know so
much about this everyone is saying how
do you know so much about this say that
and and and how does that feel how does
it feel to say out loud how do you know
so much about this let me tell you how
it should feel [ __ ] embarrassing
okay dude I'm a professional stand-up
comedian okay it's literally what I do
day in day out
I never pretty much I'm not thinking
about being a comedian or trying to be
funny or making jokes I've never ever
said or thought how do I know so much
about this I've never thought that about
anything so if you think that you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you say that [ __ ] my
carcass okay you're you're a [ __ ] out
to lunch egomaniac lunatic all right
that is just insane that's the whole
reason why the office is a successful
show because it's funny when
[ __ ] say [ __ ] like that and if
you're saying that with no irony if
you're not Brian Cowen peeling off in
his Tesla after that you are an insane
egomaniac period I don't care what you
say
about if you're pro top or against Trump
if you think saying that is normal a
craze now I have stuff to say about
Biden after this after after these
messages we'll be right back
native did you know that many
conventional deodorants contain a loom
aluminum did you know that I didn't know
that until about a [ __ ] year ago when
my buddy Craig who's a STONER told me
that forms a plug in your sweat glands
to keep you from sweating now is that
natural no should you be doing that no I
got question here the tea you use the
tea mm what is it on the thing T 100
what is it on the teeth anyway do it
look
yikes that's gross clogging up your
pores a robot natives deodorant is made
without aluminum so you can feel better
about what you're putting on your body
now I'm hip to this train dude you boys
been doing this it's safe native urine
is formulated without aluminum parabens
or talc
it's also vegan and never tested on
animals now that's cool
if you're Whitney Cummings or if you
love animals ingredients you know
interviewer is made with the ingredients
you've heard of like coconut oil and
shea butter you were deodorant everyday
and I've been putting it under my
armpits and people have been smelling me
and dreaming they smell me and they go
oh it's great no risk to try free
shipping on every order and native
offers 30 you got to get on this because
you're clogging up your pores with
aluminum and stuff it's bad for you this
stuff
it creates cancer it sucks for you it's
bad for your body for 20% off your first
purchase visit native deodorant calm and
use promo code congrats during checkout
that's 20% off your first purchase at
native deodorant calm use promo code
Congrats and I'm telling you the truth I
do use this and I love it shipstation
when you're selling online getting your
orders out can be a real pain how do you
keep track of who gets what which
shipping carrier should you use are you
getting the best rates
that's why you need shipstation calm
it's the fastest easiest and most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders just a few clicks and you'll be
managing your orders printing out labels
and getting your product
fast to keep your customers happy
shipstation makes it easy
shipstation helps you get orders I'll
quickly save money on shipping costs and
keeps your customers happy I use
shipstation
for all my merch do you have my merch I
use shipstation to get it to you my fans
always tweet me about how fast I get
their order sometimes the next day
they're like wha give a time machine no
matter where you're selling Amazon Etsy
or your own website whatever ship
station it's the baingan way to do it it
brings all your orders into one simple
interface making them is really easy to
manage from any device even on your cell
phone and right now congratulations with
Krista Lea listeners can try shipstation
free for 60 days when you use offer code
Congrats there's absolutely no risk you
can start your free trial without even
entering your credit card info just
visit ship station comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and shut and type in congrats
that's ship station calm then enter code
Congrats ship station comm make ship
happen um yeah so everyone's asking
yourself everyone's asking me how do you
know so much about this about science
you know like that's one thing like say
it about [ __ ] tacos everyone's asking
me how do you know so much about tacos
also who's everybody how many people are
saying dude everybody's saying yeah yeah
like I saw a post the other day
everyone's saying not to worry about the
coronavirus who who's saying not who is
saying at this point not to worry about
the coronavirus I I don't see it some
idiot on like some [ __ ] I don't know
if it's Facebook or why don't really do
Facebook but everyone's saying don't
worry about the coronavirus got question
oh because everyone's saying worry about
it if you're saying everyone is saying
it at least what at least bare minimum
ten people have said it so you're
telling me ten people have told you
Trump boy how do you know so much about
science
yes men are out of control maybe but it
looks like Biden's gonna be the
Democratic nominee man he's taking it
away from Bernie Sanders which by the
way there's one sigh of relief because I
think Bernie I don't know [ __ ] about
politics and I don't even really talk
about politics maybe in a perfect world
Bernie might be a good candidate but
dude if he won it would just be
pandemonium talk about the [ __ ]
coronavirus they'll be the least of our
them the right and the left will be so
at or but Biden at least I know some
Republicans that voted for Trump will be
like all right I'll go with Biden now
the problem with Biden what is he ever
talking about the problem with Biden
what is he ever talking about the thing
about Biden is he's got [ __ ] you're
not old to me until somebody says here's
the test for an old person if a gun went
off wherever you are okay this is the
proper reaction imagine Biden knew in
that there's no way that's the old guy
test if a gun goes off and you don't go
you're an old guy this is what an old
guy would do if a gun went off and this
is what very much Biden would do wow
this is actually so true you have to
watch the part guys to get this one this
is what Biden would do [ __ ] it's about
28 minutes in if you're listening if
you're watching this is what Biden would
do if a gun went off wow this is what
Biden would do
that's what an old guy does if a gun
goes off that means you're too old
that's the [ __ ] test if you go you're
good
here's my vote you're not too old but if
you're too old this is how you reacted
to a gunshot
that's what hey Biden yeah you're too
old dude who said it
Hey hos there who's there he act like
the lights are out for three seconds oh
yeah yeah whoa you saw when Biden talked
to his [ __ ] I said he was [ __ ] his
because sister or whatever the hell it
was yeah my sister my wife my beautiful
wife of [ __ ] 95 years and he brings
her in oh that's my sister okay this is
how I go at the ballot this how I go at
the ballot when he does that
oh wait this how I go well I go well I
well I don't want I go here we go Biden
and Biden big but here we go I [ __ ]
myself
okay what you're doing what bro that
[ __ ] killed me
I think Biden could be a dope president
ten years ago the [ __ ] [ __ ] man that
the whole things these are our options
these are our options in 2020 literally
everybody's dying and we're picking
between airplane food and hospital food
swear to god I'd rather vote for [ __ ]
I don't know I still think Joe Rogan
should run iiiii jet dude I don't know
man
I don't know who I'm I I don't know
who's gonna get it but the whole thing's
insane what I don't understand that
Trump is doing is I don't understand why
he's not acting I guess there's the
whole thing where he's acting like the
corona virus isn't a big deal because he
wants the economy to be okay and intact
but I feel like he's so fear-based like
that he I'm surprised he's not saying
like you guys need me to take care of
this corona virus otherwise we're
[ __ ] all dead I'm surprised he's not
doing that um but I guess he needs to
because the economy needs to be intact
if he's gonna win cuz that's really what
he's running on because the economy's
well it was good now it's bad because
China [ __ ] ruined hmm no no it's all
good it's just out China people enjoying
a live rat it's all good no but I'm I
mean not trying to be now obvious I'm
not being I'm not making a blanket
statement I'm not being racist class Oh
video okay in China picks up alive well
where the chopstick in puts in his mouth
and shootings anyway um
no no but it's all good but not trying
no I'm obviously not racist everyone
everyone everyone obviously deserves a
[ __ ] full beautiful life so yeah a
bad suit so good so um anyway
um so you know just stop eating bats huh
am i ignorant I don't know
for [ __ ] sake dude there was one too
late
apparently there was like a two-week
window in the Spanish flu where they
were like that's all good and then in
two weeks
[ __ ] hundreds of millions of people
died and then they had to stop
interstate travel and that's what
finally cured it but now we have planes
and trains and all the [ __ ] shits so
we're [ __ ]
all good I'm at the Comedy Store using
hand sanitizer like it's [ __ ] cocaine
there's like you can't even buy it
got a guy opening his jacket being like
you want baby wipes um this was the
[ __ ] thing that killed me the other
day god this was funny look at these
[ __ ] everyone's crazy by the way the
right and the left where is the [ __ ]
thing here
here we go Ken Buck congressman Ken Buck
I have just one wish message for Joe
Biden and beta O'Rourke if you want to
take everyone's ar-15s
why do you swing by why don't you swing
by my office in Washington DC and start
with this one and then he puts this
video actually on the Internet now this
whole thing is very [ __ ] okay first of
all it's a video of him with a red tie
course on any standing in front of a
wall with a [ __ ] map of the world on
it to his left course and two pictures
of him one of him seems like a [ __ ]
congressman headshot and then another
one is him meeting somebody probably
like Clint Eastwood or something of
course and then the wall is beige course
course and then on top of those two
pictures there's an a [ __ ] ar-15 that
has 40 American flags painted on it okay
it has 40 American flags painted on it a
lot hey dude we get it the American and
he the guy looks like a child molester
fine that's cool whatever but
Congressman Ken Buck posts this [ __ ]
he posted this this wasn't a leaked
video this isn't a kin stand peel sketch
check it out
cat check this video out sir echoey okay
hey guy get a love Mike hey dude you're
a rich congressman get a lavaliere you
know how about this get a [ __ ] carpet
uh or subtitle it like it no we got to
get it out quick we can't work we did
sometimes gonna take an extra day get it
out quick thought he killed it dude
first of all I'm sorry but a sec away Oh
[Music]
fill in himself so goddamn hard after he
says Joe Biden Joe Biden and the way he
lingers on that so what'd you swing by
my office it's so [ __ ] this [ __ ] to be
so so Cavalier and confident and with a
little bit of swag when you know the
hottest slam of the century is right
under your lapel you know the hottest
slam of the century is coming your way
and he says wanted to swing by my office
and and he has the hottest [ __ ] slam
you know why it's a how-to slam well
check this out this way first of all
pics up momentarily swings it aim
momentarily aims that at the cameraman
which eat which okay fine so I tweeted
Oh swung it at the cameraman and people
were like it's not even real dude okay
well then give me the Don are you gonna
threaten me with a non-working gun que
gam it's gonna be fine okay it's not a
threat then dude this kind of guy bro so
[ __ ] it
I'm sorry but this deserves one of these
really does oh if the video ended for
that I don't give a [ __ ] I'd vote for
whoever you wanted me to I'm just saying
I have a message you know this is the
message you don't have to do already
shooting dude how about this beta or
rock dropped dropped out in November
hey guy I have a message for Michael
Dukakis I'm a message from Michael
Dukakis
ran against George Bush in the 80s if
you want to take away everyone's ar-15
oh won't you start with this one come
and take it
Michael Dukakis comes in four foot ten
total dude yeah so come and take it dude
so then I was like dude I tweeted are
you so you're threatening you're
threatening to kill Joe Biden you're
threatening to kill baito O'Rourke hey
you know what beta will work change your
[ __ ] name dude if you're gonna be a
Roark then don't be beta beta O'Rourke
it's like I'm like [ __ ] King speech
doing an III beta O'Rourke dude I will
mention King's Speech every [ __ ]
podcast and that's it dude and that's it
people see I say online whoa you see
crystally always going to
yeah I'm gonna do that dude alright
ai-ai-ai-aight and I'll get [ __ ] I'll
make it more and more hardcore alright
episode 200 I like my head will explode
anyway I wrote so you're gonna kill Joe
Biden so you're say you're gonna kill
bait or work like your public is stating
a video you're gonna murder a
presidential candidate I would have
[ __ ] [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] and people
are like you didn't say that dude that's
my favorite argument yeah no [ __ ] man do
you know how threats work do you know
how [ __ ] what implied means what what
do you think what's it gonna do taking
the [ __ ] Applebee's or she gonna do
by oh I don't understand that's what a
threat is you literally just threatened
the presidential candidate and this guy
you know an 11 year old qualified for
the Olympics well that's how you know
the Olympics are [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
guy
oh you're throwing the javelin cool
let's make some new supports dude I'm
tired of this [ __ ] throwing a ball 12
feet
I'm tired of the [ __ ] skiing stopping
and shooting in a [ __ ] bullseye Hey
Dude it's 2020 yeah it's hard
yeah people work all their lives to
[ __ ] do it okay
that doesn't mean it's good just cause
something's hard to do doesn't mean it's
good that's the whole thing man Wow
impressive breakdancing I'm surprised
that's not a [ __ ] sport in the
Olympics where they they play the the
breakdancing [ __ ] and then and then
people are just like breakdancing is
just because you're good at moving your
body like a robot doesn't mean that
that's doesn't mean just cause it's hard
to do doesn't mean it's good that's the
[ __ ] number-one break dance song pop
up up up up above the pump of a pump of
a pump pump it up
ain't no palpable bump
[ __ ] talk about King speech night I
died
I lie well no other podcast will make
that noise that's the number one when
you hear that you're a [ __ ]
breakdancer dude Joe Budden pump it up
dude I [ __ ] loved that song my
shoulders would start moving when I had
that song dude remember that [ __ ] know
right hey rap videos never have an intro
I'm all good
oh what's gonna be oh there's gonna be
chicks around you're gonna be smoking
blunts I'm all good bro I'll take you
back to [ __ ] 2009 yep come on with me
dude he puts in a VHS tape dude that's
how you know it's on no reason for this
[ __ ] terrifying music you know dude
everyone's a breakdancer when you put
that [ __ ] on pump up up up up up up up
up a pump of a pump pump it up and came
to when I babe some name a day babes and
I'm raining the babes a name but doesn't
matter what he's saying
the number-one song doesn't matter what
he's saying bro you ever heard a [ __ ]
[ __ ] this dude this is the number one
doesn't matter what the [ __ ] he's saying
song this [ __ ] is banging so hard that
it's so on it's unbelievable and you
could quote me on from the [ __ ]
second second in the song dude they were
like do you want it the beat to [ __ ]
go a little bit and la cote was like nah
whose time to start not making sense
dawg
they call me big LA first of all they
don't big pet big sell a no just
immediate no they call me big LA no they
don't big pele big sell a big chili when
you're whipping in the malls would you
tell a when you're sipping in the bars
in the chili would it be this in the
fall in the backs they call me be
no they don't once that went one slidin
in the mall can you hear me dude when I
found out when I was a kid
LL Cool J stood for ladies love cool
James
that was my first I was a kid and I went
oh this podcast makes no sense
[ __ ] PR dude they call me Big L a they
call me no they don't and I love you LL
Cool J they call me Big L a call me Big
L a when you see me on the [ __ ]
Street call me big cell a I swear to God
call me big cell a I'll kiss your
[ __ ] mouth coronavirus are not dick
on you're not I don't give a [ __ ] one
time I took a picture outside the Comedy
Store and it's 65 year old woman said
can I get a picture and I said sure and
gave her phone to another person they
took a shot and right before they took a
shot she [ __ ] grab my [ __ ] real hard
and honked it and I forgot about it for
years that's how [ __ ] gangster I am
dude they call me yeah they do I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah they do one fire keeps
telling me [ __ ] do ads but I'm on
this [ __ ] LL Cool J tip dude they
call me B I thought when people do this
[ __ ] dance when they pretend like
when they do like oh [ __ ] when the guy
comes into circle and he [ __ ]
pretends to pull his heart out and he's
not even touching his [ __ ] bro if
you're a breakdancer and everyone's
doing the [ __ ] twisties and [ __ ] and
they're on their tailbone twisting
around and on one hand and they do the
thing where they split the legs on one
hand and they do a handstand that's cool
that's all fun in games and that's great
but when a guy comes up and does little
baby baby [ __ ] robot steps like a
[ __ ] twisty like one of those monkey
symbol things when they do that the
twisting fun [ __ ] things and when a
guy comes up and does a little like he's
a robot
and then [ __ ] makes his chest
[ __ ] not concave but what's the other
pumps his chest with the with the with
the fingers without even touching it bro
when a guy does that they call me that
guy's big cell eh
I swear to God the guy who does that
dance over ego you go home you do one
pump Oh shitty that it that's it let's
go home I don't care if we're out of
[ __ ] it doesn't matter if we're to
dig concert stop breakdancing you know
spinning around get a job these
[ __ ] just spinning around
thirty-four-year-old just spit in the
[ __ ] around in loose-fitting clothing
just how will loose hey dancers how
loose can you get your clothes we get it
dude so many dancers dress and [ __ ]
like Kobe jerseys and like big-ass
sweatpants that they got from like oh
this this I paid $15 for it really it's
nothing it's no big deal but you're
fashionable but you're not fashionable
but you're fashionable
all right big sell a bro LL Cool J's the
che I did a [ __ ] and when I did lip sync
battle forget it dude that guy you know
we were doing you know he would say we
were doing clowning honey you know that
honey
is the free online shipping tool that
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart right
right you do know that you know that
right or do you live under a rock or are
you paying too much for things you know
how great it feels to save right yeah
cuz you're not a corpse but how does it
feel to save with honey while saving
with honey it feels like you know what
it feels like
zipping into a train right as the doors
close hitting all the green lights on
your way to wherever the you know
something something fun even finishing
up your podcast episode right when you
walk into work or maybe it feels like
when you get to work and you have the
podcasts all stacked and you're gonna
listen to him all day it feels like
opening in that can of cold bro honey
has found over 18 million members over
two billion dollars in saving Wow did
you know that honey supports over 30,000
stores online including Macy's Target
Sephora Best Buy and more and there
every day it has over a hundred thousand
five star reviews on Google Chrome on
the Google Chrome store one just bought
me a bunch of stuff for the pod room on
Amazon and saved like 49 dollars without
doing anything extra with honey using
honey feels great think of it as a
little daily victory plus it's free to
use and installs in just a few seconds
get honey for free at joint at join
honeycomb slash Congrats
that's joined join honeycomb / Congrats
dude we corrected ourselves on the
commercial dude who my big sell a we
call it they call me big la big sell a
big pal a big chale when you whipping in
the malls in Fla when you're Crippen in
the paws in the foot gotta get your head
sprung [ __ ] yeah dude I do have to get
my head sprung I gotta go to the doctor
get my head sprung um so anyway dude how
about when [ __ ] Hulk Hogan said this
anyway no no no it's all good but how
about when [ __ ] no no it honestly
it's all good but how about when Hong
Kong and said this get off by cranking
your nob sexual I'm gonna jerk your off
and then I'm gonna [ __ ] basically what he
said [ __ ] yeah dude there's so many
goddamn rappers now rich boy or that's
an old one throw some D's on it remember
four and then the baby and lil baby
they're in a feud bro that's hilarious
hey duh baby and lil baby were in a feud
last week
hey that's [ __ ] hilarious you guys
are whining to each other and babies in
both your names you knew they were gonna
get [ __ ] in ulleungdo baby well I'm
little baby so we're gonna have a
problem okay cool
I love the joke about how [ __ ]
I love the joke about how their album
would be called maybe I gotta go potty I
[ __ ] think that that's soap when I
was talking about the Olympics and the
[ __ ] thing I put it I put a thing on
the on the internet and I was like the
eleven-year-old doing the Olympics I
said uh what's what you're gonna take
gold in going potty bro I love that joke
and I stand by it and I don't give a
[ __ ] and I'll always do that joke watch
porn last night all good um so yeah
Netflix no pain that's coming out April
14th [ __ ] put that in your
queue Netflix no pain that's a good
title it's a [ __ ] good title so check
that out dude I wonder uh if what the
coronavirus is gonna be going on if it's
gonna be terrific ansel i know
corporations are [ __ ] getting scared
and stuff like that
oh yeah hell yeah just got some cool DMS
from [ __ ] bodega bodega
I love bodega that store in Boston
Street where huh I can't stop I have the
bro one time Neal Brennan said hey how
many outfits do you have to me and that
[ __ ] was hilarious and it was also
something I need to thank him about it
because I want [ __ ] to know
about me and my outfits bro I can't wait
to get to though you don't understand
you do not understand if I get to the
level of Kevin Hart sparkly jeans galore
like it's and I'm telling you now and
somebody when I get to that level when
I'm playing arenas that's it
zippers [ __ ] that
velcro just hot they're gonna literally
look at me and be like wow he's big Sal
a because dude I'm not dressing the same
anymore I want to dress so nuts that
[ __ ]
look at me and think that they can't
talk to me you understand I was at the
Comedy Store the other night trying to
get coronavirus and I was a guy stepped
off stage I ruined Brian counts I went
on Brian Collins
stage with Bryan Callen and I [ __ ] I
put on my Instagram you can go check it
out Instagram TV but I played with him a
little bit on stage by cranking his knob
I'm gonna get off by cranking his knob
and then and then I got off stage I
walked to the down to the past the
hallway the Comedy Store which by the
way is just a cesspool of weirdos like
Rogan doesn't even hang out there I got
to do that but I want to have fun bro I
want to be out there you know and I mean
he's got way crazier fans than I do I
would think or more I would say I have
some crazy ones but he's definitely got
more I mean anyway this guy comes up to
me hey man can I ask you for some advice
and dude the answer to that is yes you
can if you're a budding comedian and
you're thinking about getting on stage
and you're gonna do it and you're not
just talking about it and you want
advice and you want to ask me about it
at the Comedy Store and you got the
balls to come up to me or any of the
other comedians props to you and ask for
advice in a true way the answer is yes I
want to help and I say of course man
fire our way I'm walking to my car but
you know as long as I it takes for me to
walk in this hallway you got my
attention and he says okay so I just
moved to LA and this and that and I was
wondering about you know when I moved to
LA there's a lot of you know people out
here that's like they're like fake and
stuff and it's it's fine but I come from
you know Philadelphia and I was just
wondering what what I should do and I
said oh whoa you're a comedian yeah and
he said no I kind of like I work in
stocks and all that [ __ ] and I say oh
well what do you want and he said well
it's just like kind of fake here in LA
and you know it feels like I said hey
bro I don't know what to tell you if
you're not asking me advice about B
comedian what do you want me to say and
he was like oh I don't know I just feel
like you know people in LA and then and
he started selling like Joe Biden and I
was just like bro I got a go do you know
why because of course because this
situation sucks and you put both of us
in it I was just walking and you were
just a stock guy you work in stocks and
you want advice from a guy who talks
about [ __ ] and sucking by himself in
his basement oh hey guy my advice to you
is don't ask me [ __ ] they call me dude
here's the deal man
Bernie was cool when he came on and he
said look the writing's on the wall you
know you guys might not have me as a
president but if what Biden needs to do
this is what Biden needs to do if he
wants to get the young people and he
handed it off to Biden and that was a
[ __ ] noble awesome thing for Bernie
to do it really was saying Biden you can
have the support but this is what you
need to do to get the young vote because
Bernie has a young vote vote okay now
that's great it's all Biden's for the
taking the only thing I'm worried about
is Biden's going to do now a press
conference about this and just start
talking about pants for no reason
do you know what I mean like I feel like
he's just gonna be like oh so how do you
feel about Bernie and he's gonna be well
you know when I was young you know I had
pants and I would take from my pants
okay
and I would taper both pants and we
would call it pegging you know you would
tuck it in and then you turn it over and
then to make it tight now every now and
then those pagans would come out and the
Bandit wouldn't be and it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be that way you know you get
wide pay so what I realized
I just start getting wider bootcut pants
yeah and so you know since I have
bootcut pants when I was a kid I stick
with that now but mostly I'm wearing
suits and I think that the young people
can really identify with boot boot cut
you know it may not be wearing suits but
you certainly can wear bootcut pant and
we just are gonna start hearing this
[ __ ] [ __ ] a lot more over the next
four years
ooh by Dan is if the gun goes off
look shook that's all you got to do do
it
and you can be big fella you could take
this [ __ ]
and run with it what Obama thinks about
all this [ __ ]
everybody's gonna be corrupt in [ __ ]
at that level this is why I wanted
Buddha jej I mean I know he's boring and
[ __ ] and needs a tan but dude I feel by
the way wanted I wanted Buddha jej and
Trump to be the [ __ ] nominees because
our the the candidates because that just
seeing the two of them together tain't a
trump looking like a Simpson and Buddha
judge looking like a corpse
I mean Buddha judge is a new color I've
never been seen that color and I'm pale
bro I look like I'd be related to a
vampire and bois de jedge just looks
like apartment blinds and this guy you
know I would have I [ __ ] love Buddha
jesh and but anyway he's not the guy but
I would have loved to seen that just
stark difference and then also just the
slams galore the slams galore dude I
mean the slams galore Trump would would
would fizz and burn and just crash and
Buddha guys would do so many slams and
just like blinking where he did the [ __ ]
he would be the meme guy where he was
just that [ __ ] blonde meme guy and do
Slams like that
um anyway I got tennis elbow
I got [ __ ] my back hurts and I'm
sweating too much and a [ __ ] yes dude
life still life rips the thing about by
the way let the life rips things just
forget it man I'm gonna have more
colorways it's gonna be this [ __ ] it's
gonna be so dope dude it's gonna be so
dope this they're they're restocked
yesterday some of the sizes sold out I'm
restocking more today go online and get
the letters rips hoodies and it's very
important for you to wear this merch at
other people's shows Bert Kreischer
Bryan Callen Tom Segura Whitney Cummings
you know Theo von Andrew Santino you
gotta wear this merch no dents doesn't
make a dent [ __ ] life life rips you
gotta wear this merch to other people's
[ __ ] shows that is the cult that is
the cult man and we are a cult and
that's all we're doing that's all we're
trying to do who knows if the [ __ ]
shows will get cancelled or whatever but
that's what's up and we're coming out
with new color ways we're gonna do that
[ __ ] and no pain
Netflix put it in your queue and April
14th I guess we did an hour huh we're
pretty good we're pretty good and I got
lunch here already so it's [ __ ] on
and poppin dude um can't wait to be
[ __ ] I don't know it's all good that's
it I guess whatever the [ __ ] what else
what else did I want to talk about one
time dude you know what I want to leave
you with this and this is how you can
tell now I'm not gonna leave you with
this because I guess I must I want to
talk about after this but one time and
this is how you know life rips this is a
life rip story and this is a [ __ ]
it's gonna be all good story one time
when I was coming up through high school
look at these hands
look these [ __ ] hands you know what
these hands are and what I've always
thought these hands are sexy hands I've
always thought I've had sexy hands ever
since I was in high school I thought I
had very masculine capable piano
fingered sexy hands that's what I've
always thought okay now
got to be a sophomore or a junior in
high school and I wondered why no girls
ever said I had sexy hands because it
never happened
and then my senior year my friend
Brandon goodie said has any girl ever
told you you had sexy hands and I was
like here it goes
Brandon's gonna tell me finally I have
sexy hands now of course is not from the
opposite sex but who cares I'll take
what I can get and I said actually no
smart and I laughed I chuckled a little
bit because I thought I knew what was
coming and Brandon said it's crazy twice
last week two different girls said I had
sexy hands and I I had never been sadder
in my life because I thought Brandon was
gonna tell me I had sexy hands or he
heard through a grapevine that Johanna
said I had sexy hands or whatever the
[ __ ] but in fact no it was the twisting
of the knife Brandon who by the way God
is my witness doesn't have sexy hands
and that's me taking me out of this
that's not even me being jealous that's
me standing away from both of us looking
at both of us thinking that if there was
somebody that didn't have sexy hands
between the two of them it would be
Brandon okay innocent bystander Chris
but that's what he said to me and I said
oh wow that's crazy
pissed pissed inside my heart I went
home you know you do you do what you do
you live life years days turned into
months months turned into years years
turn it into decades quite literally and
then your boy turns 35 one day oh I
blink and I'm 35 and I'm on a date with
a girl not really cuz I don't really do
that and I don't like to waste a lot of
time and money getting to know a girl
not because I'm cheap and not because my
time is expensive but because maybe you
[ __ ] suck girl honestly maybe we suck
together maybe we are not compatible but
getting to know each other and getting
to know if we are compatible over a
dinner that lasts one hour and thirty
minutes and is going to cost you boy
a hundred and twenty dollars that's not
my bag but I was hanging out with a girl
and I think it was that coffee because
you know me and she said you know what
you have I didn't know what was coming
it had been a long time since I talked
to Brandon goodie and even thought about
the hands thing and I said what and she
said you have really sexy hands you know
what I mean
I'm in that zone where I'm just falling
and I'm remembering I mean it's like
it's like the [ __ ] 3/4 the way
through the movie where you realize all
the guy has a history he has a past
that's what it is and it's directed
really badly by some [ __ ] second time
director that had a [ __ ] a movie that
did kind of well and then the second
movie didn't do as well because of these
kinds of [ __ ] sequences the guys
falling in it's extra ultraviolet colors
and I'm remembering what Brandon good he
said and now I'm not laughing out loud
like I did when I was with it Brenda
goody I'm keeping it to myself because
I'm older now and I'm wiser now and I'm
knowing stuff doesn't really mean
anything and lets you let it and I go
huh really and she says yeah and I said
that's funny
she says why and I said because I always
thought that I had sexy hands and nobody
ever said that until now and she said oh
yeah no totally they're really uh
they're really masculine and I went Wow
huh and guess what you boys 39 now and
I've heard that at least six or seven
times from different girls so I guess my
point is don't get so depressed when
you're in high school or something
because something happens because maybe
it'll turn out to be [ __ ] awesome
later now that's a story that means a
lot to me
and it might not mean a lot to you and
it could be oh this guy's got no
problems he's living in the first world
okay fine but problems are micro to a
macro you know maybe you're out there
and I really mean this in high school
and you're alone and you're lonely and
you're crying every day and you feel bad
about yourself and you feel about bad
about being alone about your parents
about your friends schools hard going
through puberty is hard whatever the
[ __ ] it is maybe you feel like you have
a small dick or big feet or bad acne but
I'm telling you right now
there's always that moment later on were
you it's not that you realize oh [ __ ]
I do have sexy hands it's that you
realize it doesn't matter if I do or not
so take that with you okay and just
remember life rips I have more to talk
about but I feel like we should end on
that hand story the story was like a C+
but I love you guys man some of you know
I'm honestly maybe not even most of you
because who the [ __ ] knows who you are
some of you guys are people that would
come up to me in the hallway the Comedy
Store and just start talking about
stocks and asking me for advice and all
I do is [ __ ] do impressions of The
King's Speech once a week on my [ __ ]
podcast but you guys uh thanks for
listening and remember no pain dude on
Netflix after this podcast I'm living
tweet me show me on Instagram show me
it's in your cue BAM appreciate that and
thank you my baby you can tip you can
text me at eight one eight two three
nine seventy eighty seven and yeah the
new the life rips hoodies are out and we
got I think we've got more colorways
come and do this gonna be so tailed man
I just decided to go all out you guys
are killing it I love seeing you in
those sweaters those goodies and all the
other ones thank you very much you guys
you guys are great thank you bye bye
[Music]